[Music]
is
michael jordan officially the second
best athlete of all time
that is the discussion yes you think yes
100
on this indisputable okay now why give
me give me why
i mean look what tom brady did can you
imagine michael jordan going to a second
team
and winning a championship i think he
didn't even get to the playoffs
yeah when 75 percent of your conference
gets to the playoffs
mj was 40 years old i know i know he
can't do anything he's doing it
how could he possibly compete with all
these young bucks who are so athletic
and brilliant
the game is to completely change how
could he compete with them at 40.
yep i mean how old was tom oh tommy 43
oh he was older much older
interesting okay okay three years big
difference
people make a big deal about i was
talking to somebody's in the group chat
and they also brought up the different
team thing i don't think people realize
how difficult it is to win with another
team
it's incredibly hard also but why break
it down why
you're going to a different system yes
you're he's going to a different
conference so he's playing different
teams pretty much all together
every team he sees is different if
you're in the same team you play
almost half your schedule every year
against the same division opponents
right he knows the buffalo bills inside
and out
now he's playing the saints twice and he
got curb stomped twice
and then in the playoffs he was like no
i got it now
it's good now right right now he's going
to completely new personnel completely
new culture completely new city yeah
everything is different yeah everything
is different yeah but here's what tom
brady is
tom brady is you know people that say
like it's a vibe tom brady is a culture
yes tom brady comes to your team and now
the entire culture is tom brady's
culture he will take your misfits
yes and make them magical yes i mean
antonio brown
hasn't said a peep since he moved into
tom brady's pool house
bruh leonard fournette who's little
talkie talkie
got yolk who's a little talking working
jacksonville they got rid of him and he
was a high draft pick and they were like
he was nice yeah and coughlin was like i
don't want to deal with this little
talking
tom coughlin who's a guy who manages
egos very well
yes couldn't manage the ego yes both of
them
i think there might be one more player
on the team i'm forgetting right now oh
uh
suh oh and dominican i don't know how to
[ __ ] pronounce his first name yeah no
vowel having [ __ ]
i would never say that's someone who
never got made fun of for their first
name isn't that crazy
or his last name so
you can chase me but point is he got all
these guys
yeah who were i mean leonard fournette's
only been
in the league for a few years but had
the
had the stigma over them that they were
really tough guys to get to buy in
yes and he has this magical ability to
get people to buy in
antonio brown that touchdown was a great
route he threw it also also goat [ __ ]
that was after he went a tired matthew
and went in his face and was like i'm
going after you all [ __ ] games yeah
i don't know what happened what guy said
we'll talk about tyron being in there
[ __ ] [ __ ] he said something i won't
repeat
what's up what's gross about that is
he's trying to imply some [ __ ] that he
said the end
he just called him a [ __ ] no i oh i
know i didn't go n word with it there's
no way that he said
i thought that's what he was trying to
do you really think i know no way
is dropping the n word no chance come on
i thought that's what he was trying to
believe
after he retires he's going to say that
[ __ ] a lot but i think he wants to come
back next time brady got so much respect
if you're his teammate and he said it to
you be like you're right you think he's
that bad antonio brown be like yo could
tom brady say the n word with the a at
the end
yeah yeah 100 percent i bet you tom
you're trying to sing along
to a rap song with the a at the end and
not a single p
from anybody a at the end yo i bet him
and antonio brown play yg
like it's nothing like they both just
sing along let's do it yeah
yeah and tony around is with it
[Laughter]
sing that [ __ ] yes you are here's how
this is how much he got antonio brown to
buy in this was the most look at me
[ __ ]
in the league antonio brown scores a
touchdown in the super bowl do you know
what he does what
drops to his knees raises his arms up to
god to say thank you
yeah and by god you mean tom brady
by god you mean tom brady let's be
honest here's why i also i also want him
to be the goat
because he seems like much less of a
[ __ ] than every other goat
he's mike pence to me explain
personality-wise
he's a politician he's a consummate
politician like even mike pence
who i don't think we heard speak for
three years
yeah right and everybody's like this guy
wants to
turn gay straight through conversion
therapy and he's a piece of [ __ ] and
what an [ __ ] and the second we saw
him in that debate we're like
this guy's got a president yeah he looks
like a nice guy
he wouldn't hurt a fly i mean he's the
sweetest human being
like literally he was very literally he
didn't hurt a fly just sadness
refused not gonna do it this is the
christianity
so he seemed like this really straight
guy and like
incredibly polished like any time he
tried to pin anything on him he said the
right thing and i think that's tom
i have no clue who tom brady really is
so he could be
the sweetest man ever and know exactly
what to say in every single moment the
guys were coming up to him in the locker
room do you see that
and they're like uh we got number one
for me but number seven for you tom we
got and he was like
we just got one that's all that matters
right now is we all got
definitely political and they're simple
a little sociopathy to him but here's
what i point to yep
the belichick versus brady thing who did
rob gronkowski
come out of retirement for oh of course
i want to get to that
teammates all [ __ ] love him i heard
the first and again this could be
[ __ ] narrative but i still like it
i heard the first thing tom brady did
after he signed with the bucks is he's
like yo i want every teammate's phone
number so i can reach out to them
yes yes yes like that if you're willing
to do all that
all right fine even if it's a little
phony you're putting in a lot of effort
to be phony
right and nobody's gonna see they're
gonna buy in and that's dope
that's like you working real hard to be
phony yeah so phony that it's kind of
genuine
well that's the thing i don't know if
he's phony or not
okay right i'm not sure i think that we
don't know a lot about tom brady which i
also like
i think that's cool there's some mystery
to him he's a throwback he's marlon
brando
yeah you know what i mean he's one of
these figures that
we get what he decides to give us yeah
he's got a sense of humor clearly
like on his instagram he's aware of the
things that he's posting are funny
he's kind of culturally aware like if
you notice like even the music that he
chooses
in the videos it's all hip-hop yeah is
everything sit right like he's going for
it like
this is supposed to be mega tom brady
he's not doing a luke bryant
no wherever these [ __ ] country guys
are what's your boy
who is dropping them bombs oh my god
morgan you know i mean you're a boy
bro he's one of you in the neighborhood
he might drop a couple of them
the coolest i would ever feel the point
being
like we're on we know that he's aware of
the culture we know he's aware of what
people are saying about him
like he's on social media yeah he's
responding to
themes that happen within social media
right
he's responding to people responding to
his content
yes right so he knows what's going on
he's aware of this
he's commented on little duval posts
this year remember if you're explaining
you're losing
yeah duval has some meme about a guy
getting yelled at by his girl yeah and
thomas is like if you're explaining
you're losing
boom gee [ __ ] dog that's some g-shape i
don't imagine tom brady
in his house scrolling instagram and
like seeing what people are saying about
him i don't imagine
even needing that at all but clearly
he's aware of it and clearly he knows
how to play that part of the game
i think there's a part of tom brady that
maybe we might get to witness
on like a long-form howard stern
interview you know like howard got to
expose certain people
that you really never knew that side of
them yeah like maybe we'll see that one
day
but i think there's a part of tom that
we do not know about
because like we don't even really know
his strategy for greatness
no like i've been thinking about this a
lot
there are certain greats that share
their greatness
how they got to the mountaintop right
the only thing we know about tom is tb12
is the stuff he sells you isn't that
interesting like avocado ice cream is
the reason why you're the greatest
athlete of all time
no nightshades that's it apparently
his diet is he's like public about it
but still you don't know
how locked in he's you don't know you
don't hear all the [ __ ] also what a
[ __ ] idiot bill belichick is for
kicking out the tb12
oh my god like what a [ __ ] buffoon
we're gonna get to belichick in a little
bit
but literally he's just hey i just want
to keep working out the way i've worked
out that won me uh six championships is
that cool
no kick him off get the guy whatever
alex garcia
or whatever whatever his [ __ ] name
latin name kick his ass out he's not
allowed to access to the facility i mean
like what a
mind-boggling idiot bill belichick is
for the decision-making that he had
around tom brady whatever he needs
to be victorious you feed the man you
rock with it
okay but back to like sharing greatness
like
jordan put out a whole documentary kind
of sharing his greatness
yeah but also very much controlling the
narrative of what went out
but he's controlling the narrative of
like how they got to the mountaintop
as a team yeah but it was not lost on
any of us watching
what he had to do in his commitment to
the game and what he was willing to give
right right yeah his whole thing was i'm
willing to give everything yeah and my
motor lasts longer than all your motors
and i'm willing to work harder and i'm
more maniacal and i can stay up to two
in the morning and be up at six in the
morning that you are i'll outwork
everybody yeah right and i think tom
brady's a hard work guy
i don't wanna let me go this is another
tom brady versus mj thing and this is
why tom brady is better yeah jordan can
stay up all night
tom brady won't stay up all night you
see what i'm saying
jordan couldn't play when he came back
at 40 because he had been drinking for
two years and partying jordan was a
party guy
tom brady i'm going to get 10 hours of
sleep every single piece of my life
is dedicated to this greatness jordan
was like that but he still partied
tom is like even that i don't need it i
am not willing to say that tom brady is
better than michael jordan
just yet i know you're willing and you
are probably being way more objective
than i am
and you're holding on to jordan i'm
holding on to jordan and i think that
there is something
just about the word athlete that like i
just look at tom brady's
i will say this i think that tom brady
is a much better
leader than michael jordan that's part
of why i'm biased is i want
that guy to be the leader that's just
like yes not everybody hates you but the
reason why i'm saying that
is because tom brady has to manage more
characters yeah when you're on a
football team
you got 50 plus guys yeah that you have
to get on board and you have to buy in
and each one of those people
has to buy into something that might not
directly affect you
yeah right you have to get those linemen
to fight every single place
right you got to get he's got to be on
the defense as well
yeah he's got to get every one of those
corners to fight every single play every
one of those safeties fight every single
play
he's got to get his wide receivers to
run their asses off
for a run play yeah dude he's gonna do
everything that he possibly can to get
these and motivate all these people
michael jordan has to motivate four
other people that are on the floor with
him at that time
yeah he don't even care what the bench
guys do when he's not in the game
cause he's like i'm about to go make
this up when i get back in there you
have much more personal control on the
sport
so while we'll never know if
tom brady could impact the game in the
same way that michael jordan could
impact the game
because they don't the sports don't
compare in that way
we do know that he was able to motivate
more people yes to greatness than jordan
was yes
and that's something you brought up in
the last episode and that's where i say
tom brady is a culture and what you just
touched on
everybody saw what tom brady was saw how
he worked
and everybody elevated their game people
are saying like haters are like
man any quarterback could have won the
game his stat line wasn't that great
that one
was good that line was right for 29 200
yards what three tds 200 yards a little
low so at least he's ever thrown four
second least he's thrown four in a win
but it's a blowout yeah also
you're just running the ball he knows
how to win that's it there was a play
against the packers
when he kicked the field goal to go up
eight yeah he just saw the defense and
instead of taking a hit as soon as the
ball was snapped he saw a guy unblocked
and he just threw the ball on the ground
didn't try to gain a yard didn't try to
make a play happen and troy aikman was
like a lot of people thought that was
like
he just mailed on the play troy troy was
like no tom brady's so aware he knows we
need these three points i cannot take a
sack
just throw the ball away who gives a
[ __ ] just do it and that's where tom
brady's hyper aware and i think the stat
line
played into like the hyper situational
awareness this is how we win
but defense played their ass off yeah a
lot of it was chiefs
two tackles are injured and no
quarterback can overcome that i'm
realizing
but everybody elevates their game
because you see what tom brady is doing
you know how great he is i can't let
this guy down i gotta work like him i
gotta lock in like him yeah he straight
kicked his family
out of his house for two weeks before
the super bowl he was by himself
tom brady tom brady slumber party
every single gronk come on over watching
doing tick tocks
watching film eating avocado ice cream
love it he is a culture
you bring tom brady to your team
everything changes everybody elevates
their game and that's
jordan would do that but also [ __ ] on
you and yell and yell at you and break
you
tom brady's like nah i just lead by
example you just follow what i do we're
good that's it
the tom brady way god bless the goat tom
brady
i still can't give him the goat over
jordan that's just not where i am
but i i respect why are you saying
adorable that you hold on to that no no
you were being more objective than me
i mean he's on emotional journey he's
grieving i don't own any of
brady's stuff like i don't have uggs you
know what i mean i have a jersey
tom brady will never move culture so
maybe i'm attracted to the investment
that i've made in jordan
like my sneakers are gonna take a hit a
lot of things taking a hit right yeah
yeah you know same so i can't i can't
really have that
right i've just shattered back boards
are depreciating right real tall you're
losing all your investments
i got jordan sneakers in stupid colors
and i've had to buy specific
clothing to go with because it's so odd
you're on the short squeeze of jordan
i really am yeah so i don't want to
believe it hold the line brady's walking
hold the [ __ ] line brady's wall
street bets he's squeezing you bro
anyway um i admire your objectivity
thank you doug
let's run around the room one last time
uh mark even though you don't care about
sports besides soccer
brady or jordan probably brady
wow alex jordan not even close not even
close
and what is the rationale um i i know
this is going to sound funny
really cool if he was like ah he's black
he's blacker than the other guy
like i'm just one of those people that
connect athleticism
to the lettuce as well but that's the
case why not go with bo jackson or
something
like well he didn't have the he hasn't
won as much but if you're going off
athleticism
no no no and the win and the rings he
waits more in favor of advertising
brady appears and presents so unathletic
yeah that it's hard to beg you're the
greatest athlete of all time
you could would you call him the
greatest winner
you'd have to call him a better winner
than jordan yeah
i mean that's just statistically yeah i
could do that but then we could also go
back and say
bill russell or something yeah yeah but
it would be like if bill russell had
like 18 wins
where there's like no franchise that has
as many wins as this player
that's crazy you see what i'm saying i
hear you
it's just a tricky one right is it are
we biased
yeah yeah you guys so we're admitting
our right now we are biased
i think we're biased too like basketball
more as a sport we both played it
like yes we know the difficulty in
playing back where we don't
recognize it and you're a huge football
fan but we don't recognize it as much in
football because we never play football
so we're like nah we played this sport
it's hard
this guy was the best at it therefore
he's the best ever yeah
yeah and that's probably why i lean
towards mayweather because i have some
experience boxing well you've
experienced fighting yeah
and that's why i put mayweather up there
as well yeah also
mayweather over brady also i mean
mayweather is i think
yeah but none of my favorite athletes
growing up were athletic like they were
like soccer players or like they were
not like conventionally athletic in the
way they're like basketball players are
like messi's a freak but he's also fine
leo messi's like five
six or whatever like yeah tyrion reed is
like a skinny french dude
but i guess that athletic like if you're
they're still
fast yeah you're still fast yeah they're
fast like they're agile but like they're
not like
they're not lebron james you know what i
mean so that is the thing that's crazy
using it right it's like i don't know to
me
i know this sounds so weird but like i
see mayweather's dominance
and i liken that to lebron
i know that sounds odd we got some
blinking lights over here
but i don't know i just
the way that that lebron can like
dominate a game
physically that's what mayweather could
do
and i know that the way they play the
game is different like maybe they're so
sleek
and like can adapt to whatever situation
lebron just kind of like enforces his
will it's just like
he's this unbelievable unstoppable force
yeah and they're completely unalike but
their ability to dominate
is similar can i can i throw in an other
dominator it's just for the secure
conversation
the big three of federer nadal djokovic
plus serena williams
serena thing is so stupid serena
competition is not nearly what federer
don't know
put the other three guys in there and go
in with i'm just saying dominating
individual sport athletes
uh those guys if you look at it like
that what's crazy about federer
and djokovic the three greatest players
of all time are all playing
right now all just competing and the
only reason that federer is losing more
now is because he's the oldest
yeah that's it djokovic will pass i
believe he'll pass them
in more grand slam wins but as a group
as a collective
it's like murray had a piece of that for
years but 17 years
of pure dominance when millions of
people around the world
continue to play the sport how do they
keep winning i want to know what that's
awesome
nobody nobody cares about tennis bro
i know this is [ __ ] up but in football
you can get bailed out
brady had a bad game not the super bowl
but the game right before he had a bad
game and his defense bailed him out he
had a great first half he actually won
the game at the end of the first half
but the second
with three seconds left at your own 50
or six seconds you throw it through a
touchdown three picks like
he his defense luckily held up and
that's why he also got them at 2018
basketball no no but he's making it
i think over a game he's making a really
good point which is like
a lot of people will make the argument
that the buccaneers defense
yeah should have been the mvp of that
game yeah and
i think you could give brady the mvp too
i don't think it's that i don't think is
that black and white i think there's a
lot of gray area with that decision
right like the guy did throw three
[ __ ] touchdowns yeah and they didn't
have to do much after that
but in football you can get bailed out
and protected a lot easier here's what i
would say to bray about brady though
brady makes everyone on the team better
in a different way than in basketball
basketball lebron can get you in the
perfect spot for a shot etcetera
brady is a culture is what i'm what i i
keep saying because
just having brady with you i got
something for you i got something for
you i got something for you
one person can't affect
the game in football like one person can
affect the game in basketball right
but one person can't
affect the game negatively as much
as one person can affect the game
negatively in basketball oh yeah
right so you could hide bums
in football a little be easier they can
get exposed don't get me wrong you have
a bad corner you can expose them but you
still got a safety that can help them
out
yeah in basketball you can get
if you are whack they're going to eat
you alive
yeah i mean you see times like um
i'm trying to think uh the the golden
state warriors would expose
teams yeah when they went small ball
yeah and then the centers just couldn't
chase him around
right so i'm just wondering who gives
who is that an advantage to
is that advantage to jordan knowing that
each one of his teammates carries more
weight
does that mean that he had to do less
yeah or is that in his or is that the
advantage to
brady knowing that not only can he not
affect the game that much but nobody
around him
can affect the game singularly that much
yeah except him
he's the closest it comes to singular
like that's why the quarterback is so
important
that's the only position that touches
the ball every offensive player i don't
know the
the the end the end of the discussion is
really like tom brady has managed
to change our idea of who the greatest
ever was
at least in a discussion yeah allen you
and i might not believe it
but we have to entertain the discussion
if somebody comes up
right whenever people bring up gretzky
though it's always they're always it's
like oh [ __ ] that's really convincing
like his numbers are stupid right
apparently even if you off of
like the points in hockey is a goal and
an assist yeah
and if you take away all of wayne
gretzky's goals and just count as
assists
he still has more points than every
other player in nhl history yeah that
gets
[ __ ] crazy but it also makes me think
like they didn't have athletes yet
maybe do you know like some of these
sports are still getting athletes yeah
you know like kelly slater was like this
i don't know ten time or something like
that uh
surf champion but the greatest athletes
don't surf
right right it's a random thing to
become a surfer yeah it's like a bunch
of like skateboard kids who decide to be
in the water more than at the skate park
so they're not going to be as good
you're not going to have the super
elites and kelly was probably one of
those super elites that ended up surfing
same thing with pools right like how
many people have access to a [ __ ]
swimming pool yeah and then end up being
super fast swimmer is like michael
phelps the best swimmer
no it would be lebron yeah right but
black skinny
but but lebron isn't going to be in the
swimming pool because of like economic
reasons right
same thing with golf yeah i don't know
you could apply that to anything though
usain bolt no that's why i think usain
bolt is the greatest athlete
or i think he is because everybody's run
100 meters
and he's the fastest person to do it
yeah he's competing against everyone
the global scale like all these like
african dudes that
didn't even have the chance to like do
anything but they could run a hundred
meters they probably ran a hundred
meters way more than most
yeah maybe but then they gotta get
noticed they have to like get into a
system
if you run a hundred meters faster
that's fast you're gonna notice
there's an nfl scout watching you get
chased by a cheetah
they're like i think this guy can return
some points for real
i'm just saying that seems to me to be
like the most basic version of it the
basics are fighting and running fighting
running or height if you're seven feet
tall they're gonna find you the greek
olympic sports or whatever like
yeah like those are like the most basic
ones like wrestling
fight like running right throwing
something yeah yeah yeah anyone can do
it no matter where you are in the world
[Applause]
yeah